there were 10 people that were found to
have had peds and either suspended or
retroactively suspended thus giving the
11th place
finisher the gold medal okay so when you
i'm not kidding you 11th place to gold
medal
zach talander welcome to the show
thanks for having me back chris what's
happening man you look serious you're a
serious human today
no i'm uh you know normal stuff in in my
neck of the woods
uh weightlifting is going through its
potential
death penalty
but beyond that it's a pretty great day
well we're we're in the same city and
we've decided to do this over the
internet like i know i could shout it
out of the window we could just do it
that way yeah i'll see you tonight man
yeah catch you later on let's do this
let's do this unrecorded later but uh i
have had
48 hours from hell with this jordan
peterson
[ __ ] infected me
gave me a stomach but he poisoned me
that man was it jordan peterson or was
it a chicago style hot dog from the
chicago airport i'm blaming it on jordan
pete i'm thinking that canadian this is
an act of war from the canadians against
britain these [ __ ] polite
[ __ ] uh i don't know so i
thought that i'd eaten a dodgy hot dog
and
[Music]
that was what had caused me to wake up
at three in the morning on monday after
i'd spent the weekend in nashville with
jordan and michaela with just vomiting
sat on the toilet for like 12 hours i
haven't been that bad in dude i threw
everything i had at that illness i was
doing breath work i was doing
mindfulness practices against it i'm
pretty sure that i prayed at one point
like
i'm like
just
putting on my knees to a higher power
i've got the cushion on the floor you
were praying to the porcelain god that's
for sure correct correct i just wanted
it to end uh so i thought it was this
dodgy
hot dog that i'd had at chicago airport
and then michaela messages me on
tuesday morning oh my god chris what
have you done to us everyone in the
house is really really sick uh so the
only person suspiciously the only person
out of the entire group that was out
over the weekend that isn't ill is
jordan
so
i am classifying that as an act of war
can can i be honest with you i'm
actually really relieved it wasn't the
chicago style hot dog because that's
your hometown right
yeah well because like if you and i ever
go to chicago and you're like nope no no
hot dogs for me i will be heartbroken
is that your national food is that the
food of your people
i would say so i mean people we we like
deep dish um italian beef is another one
but chicago style hot dog man that's
like it's the greatest food on earth so
it came up in tiny increments surrounded
by
whatever else i'd had dude it was so
rough
so rough but uh
kind of was it worth it was probably
worth it it was probably worth it for a
pretty fun weekend had a pretty fun
weekend in nashville tell you what
nashville sorry to all the people from
tennis well
tennessee and nashville aren't the same
thing but anyway nashville's
much tackier than i remember and i i
can't tell if that's just because i was
exclusively on broadway which is kind of
like the main
party street there but even having seen
sixth street in austin which is that's
where the hen parties from nashville
come to but when you go to nashville
you're like oh my god this is the pro
leagues
i think nashville style country like
there's a dis there is for for country
listeners there's a distinct difference
from like nashville country which is
essentially the hollywood of country
and i think that's where the tackiness
really comes through
right it's just that that full-blown
uh bachelorette party
like fake southern tackiness um
and which is interesting you brought up
6th street which is also an incredibly
tacky area um also slightly sketchy
you and i saw rogan uh pretty recently
on sixth straight and
like leaving there is pretty sketchy yes
but you you almost felt at home though
you were like this is what newcastle
these are my people yeah but no dude i
mean
[ __ ] going to broadway in nashville
was
that turned up to 11.
my god
yeah like the the um cowboy hats the
pink sparkly cowboy hats that all of
them are wearing um
yeah that was that was an experience i
think the biggest change is because i've
come from austin especially spending
time in whatever like south austin where
it whatever you're on congress and
everyone's out in
jeans and
trainers and you're watching live music
like just chill at some italian bar or
whatever right eating tex-mex to go to
full on like kid rocks
finger blast club or whatever it's
called which is on like five floors
come and get finger blasted by kid rock
on five floors and a rooftop um it was
just it was such a such a change of pace
but i got to meet i got to meet one of
the guys that's a head producer with the
daily wire ben shapiro show colton he's
like just such a bro like really cool
spent a ton of time with jordan got to
see him record his new course that was
pretty fun
uh and got some stuff
sorted for next year as well which i'll
be able to release some details about
probably within the next few weeks which
is like [ __ ] dope
it's cool man but i i keep forgetting
you're not officially an austinite you
are going to have to go back
to your cold
dark
ominous country dead behind the eyes
well i mean i just found out today
here's a headline for you man
so um where is it covid's uk reports
highest daily cases since the pandemic
began that was today the 15th of
december the uk has reported the record
number of daily covered 19 cases since
the beginning of the pandemic with 78
610 new cases on wednesday previous
highest number was 68 000 on the 8th of
january earlier this year follows the
introduction of mandatory face masks in
most indoor settings kobit passes for
large events in england boris johnson is
due to hold a press conference
lots of people are ill lots of people
are getting booster shots uh don't come
back to this country that's basically
what that news story says to me
super
[ __ ] great [ __ ] come back chris
get yourself back here man
happy christmas yeah i know it's a weird
one it's a weird one bro but yeah back
back for christmas uh on sunday
and then uh we will see what the plan is
for now but it's been this trip's been
dope this trip has been so much fun
spending time with you doing adventures
seeing rogan training hot and cold stuff
i learned how to wake surf
it's been
it's been a good trip man you know it's
it's like a holiday but it's so much
more than that for you it feels much
like it's got to feel much more like
much less temporary yep right it's not
just an escape where you're in a nice
place you're actually kind of living
here
you know it's almost like a semester
abroad type of deal so it's it's i
imagine it's different vibes yeah well i
think
if you take satisfaction from working
and from progressing and from doing
stuff and and contributing to whatever
you think your
message is
to the world or your mission or whatever
um
one of the things that you have to deal
with if you go on holiday holiday is
well i kind of have to sacrifice my
mission in order to enjoy this trip
abroad whereas when you go away and you
kind of keep on or maybe even increase
the pace at which you do stuff you know
i've met more people
since i've been here that are in my
industry than i have done
in the previous year leading up to this
so i'm like oh actually i get the
satisfaction of contributing to the
thing that i really care about whilst
also
being away somewhere different my buddy
george mack is in dubai and i messaged
him at the start of this year asking
what does it feel like being out there
for i think he'd been there for about
three months and he said it feels like
i'm on summer holiday from school and
someone's going to come and tell me that
it's over soon but i know that it's not
over it's just it's never over until i
say that i need to go home and that's
kind of
that's kind of what it feels like that
it's just this endless
endless enjoyable
trip um i think that that's got to stem
from you and actually enjoying your work
yeah
you know you you work really hard i've
noticed you know you work um you do a
lot behind the scenes
um you're like constantly getting new
guests you're constantly editing fixing
things up you know curating stuff for
different social media but i think that
that doesn't really stress you out um
it can it can it can get to you what
i've noticed at least
but you you enjoy it so you know it
doesn't really matter where you are i
think that the the uk thing started to
wear on you especially with the pandemic
you you literally
did not change at all so
so yeah man
what's your name
i'm bummed you have to go but yeah i
know turn around and come right back i
[ __ ] i know man i know man give me
give me a bit of time uh so you
rang me this morning
in
a state of frenzy
life has never been heard before the
wrath
of a a tall
human
shouting
about some [ __ ] what's
what's occurring
so
uh essentially the sport of
weightlifting the the sport that i'm
that i'm a professional in
uh
it's under the gun again
so i don't know if do you know that meme
of james franco and he's about to be
hanged
no
where
um
i forget what the it's a it's a cohen
brothers movie but he's hanged once and
and it's unsuccessful and then he gets
hanged again and he looks over the guy
on the second time and he looks over and
he says first time
it's it's a it's a famous meme but
basically
everyone's freaking out because uh
weightlifting is quote unquote out of
the 2028 games the
the ioc had like i guess it was their
commissioner or someone spoke about this
but the verbiage did not exclusively or
sorry explicitly state that it was out
it's essentially another warning to the
iwf which is the governing body of
weightlifting
hey you need to clean your [ __ ] up
because like for real we are going to
kick you out we had this issue leading
up to 2020 which ended up being the 2021
games um it was up on the chopping block
for paris which is 2024 which we
eventually found out they were going to
include it and now they're they're
basically saying
see it's weird verbage here
they're not saying
hey you're out you have to work to get
back in they're just kind of saying like
you're up again to be out but this time
it seems a little bit more serious okay
so can you explain the different parties
that are at play here what does the iwf
do and how did the ioc
relate to that as a body so the iwf is
required to
do certain things to establish a
relationship with the ioc which is the
international olympic committee just
like any other governing body has to
establish that um
with their with the ioc they have to
establish some sort of relationship
where they follow the guidelines to be
in the olympics so
uh
in the past the
iwf has been
one of the most actually you know what i
can just outright say the most corrupt
olympic sport um i have a little quote
here it's very interesting um from
somebody who did a let's see here so
this guy named mark peath
peath or pyth i'm not entirely sure he
was an anti-corruption expert and he
actually worked on fifa and he said he
and his team did a legal study after
weeks of reviewing the iwf documents
which is the international weightlifting
federation documents
what i saw here seems very very brazen
to me more brazen than what i saw at
fifa and if we're talking about
corruption being more so than at fifa
that can give you guys the level here
uh so so what he's referring to man
there's it's just there's so much and
this is why i said my head was spinning
when i was trying to
to to uh come up with like a finite
amount
basically
to put it simply there's two branches
okay it's
uh corruption amongst the suits
so the the corruption amongst the the
boomers and suits as i like to call them
and then the corruption amongst doping
so
simply put doping since 2000 there have
been 700 cases international of doping
suspensions
um within this olympic weightlifting yes
in within the sport of olympic
weightlifting that is an astounding
number that that's
that's crazy okay so this is where so so
the other branches are anyone left to do
weightlifting
well so here's the thing in in in the uh
london olympic games in 2012 um there
was
10 people
there sorry there were 10 people that
were
found to have had peds and either
suspended or retroactively suspended
thus giving the 11th place
finisher the gold medal okay so when you
i'm not kidding you 11th place to gold
medal so so you know a great example of
this is like um you look at lance
armstrong there was a uh
there was some guy whether it was in his
documentary or in icarus and he said
i tested personally tested
uh
uh lance armstrong 50 times and he
passed every single one of them
now i believe that he passed those tests
because
they said it pretty explicitly in
that documentary it was either icarus or
it was i think it's the lance armstrong
documentary a great documentary by the
way um where
he was like a prized possession to that
the cycling federation
so
you know americans more or less did not
care about cycling before lance
armstrong and while he was hot the last
thing they'd want to do is pop this guy
and get him in trouble i mean it took a
long time for the people outside of that
federation to expose lance armstrong but
that's actually what happened
and you know what you were saying about
weightlifting how is there anyone left
to do weightlifting
when things like 2012 happens you're
absolutely right
but the main thing i think that the
doping issues are secondary to the uh
corruption which is some of this stuff
is very interesting if these guys
the heads of the iwf were outside of
sport they would be behind bars there is
no question about that and there are so
many other sports like this
they talk about this in this article
that very rarely
do these
cases of corruption within sport get
pursued in in trial in actual criminal
trials i was going to say is it a
criminal offence to cheat at sport i i
you know it i
this this sort of stuff here i'll list
off some some of the stuff over the
period of 17 years since 1992 more than
23 million dollars went into swiss imf
bank accounts bank bank accounts which
however were not listed in the iwf's
balance sheets when these accounts were
discovered in 2009 ayan alone
was authorized to sign so he was the
only one who was able to look in
ion sorry i didn't explain who that is
he is
our overlord well at least was for the
past three decades he was the president
of the iwf and this man
is like a mafioso
don so the head of a mafia there is no
other way i can describe the iwf other
than a crime syndicate
because that's really really what we're
looking at and um
according to the research ion could not
explain the whereabouts of at least 5.5
million dollars
this man had been
you know
siphoning money or he had uh you know he
bribed people to
um basically pass tests so certain
countries would pay fines to pass tests
they were always
in uh cash and they were always
delivered directly to thomas ion
and so that's the money that's in cash
plus all of these transactions that have
gone into this dodgy swiss bank account
as well so that's this that's just the
stuff that was banked
yes and and and their their theory is
that there's 5.5 million dollars missing
that that's unaccounted for there are
also 300 tests that are unaccounted for
so 300 tests that just kind of slipped
under the rug there were multiple times
where people were tested and then their
positive tests were shown years later so
that they could continue to compete
so is um is
is it the iwfs job to enact their own
testing though or do they not outsource
it to russada or usada or someone else
right so so this is what's interesting
and i'll tie it back to um
lance armstrong because because i think
a lot of people can resonate with that
we were all well aware of that that
scandal um
so
internationally
uh we use wada world anti-doping agency
and so that's going to be for world
those are for international events but
outside of that each country is required
to have national testing and this is
where you get the corruption to start
right this this the the fact and i love
love bringing this up that america has
usada and they don't really give a [ __ ]
about any weightlifter they're not going
to protect a weightlifter in the same
way that
the cycling federation may protect lance
armstrong
in the same breath though we will have a
a usada tested weightlifter compete
against a north korean
okay so
anything that north korea does
as far as national testing like there's
absolutely no way that we can reasonably
say that there is something fair going
on there especially when they end up
going into worlds uh world championships
asian championships and and winning a
lot of medals but surely as soon as the
north korean athlete gets to a world
championship level it goes away from
being tested by north korea and goes
into being tested by
wada right and there's a science behind
that you you learn how to cycle off of
the steroids and the peds you learn how
to cycle off you make sure that the
window for catching these metabolites is
closed and then you go and compete which
oh surely
okay so so what you're saying is that
wada is there to test athletes during
their competition phase at the absolute
peak but because your your national
testing isn't up to scratch
athletes are able to do more metabolic
[ __ ]
during their prep phase
and then with the right amount of
cycling off they can get themselves
stronger outside of international
testing with only national testing and
then beat the international testing when
the time comes yeah so so this is a
great point
there are three avenues for passing
tests
the first avenue is knowing when the
test is coming
the second is knowing what the test is
exactly and um the third is having a
drug that won't get tested so when
knowing when the test is coming is like
the greatest advantage in my opinion
because it's the least risk
right you you can plan out your taking
of
whatever pharmacological substance you
need
you can plan that out to make sure that
you pass the test knowing what the test
is would require you to have that
testing facility yourself so the gregory
radchenkov of icarus had he was the
leader of rusada so he had the literal
exact testing um
that that is
that was used
from wada so his athletes he would just
make sure they were clear with his own
testing and then you know they would
show up and pass tests the third would
be some sort of designer drug and i
don't know the reality of that one
actually existing but it's it's not
outside the scope of something that can
happen presumably there's a fourth route
here that you could just pay someone off
to swap samples out
yeah and
that's
the funny thing is that's exactly what
happened
that is exactly what happened in
weightlifting there was a german
documentary um called
i don't know the german term but it was
just called the lord of lifters and it
was about thomas ayan the lord he's the
overlord he is the sith lord an actual
evil evil man and in this documentary
there was a
moldovan team doctor
who said
we would just have random people show up
for the testing show the idea of the
person piss in a cup and it would piss
clean
sometimes the tester would show up and
we'd offer them the proper amount of
money and they wouldn't even collect a
sample or they would collect you know a
clean sample from someone else
this was the sort of stuff that was
happening on mass and we were able to
catch it so the is it the iwf's job to
deploy testing
yes well it is
the
it is because they
um they utilize water and there's a
requirement within iwf to have out of
competition testing that is nationally
driven
um so
that's not even really the issue the the
main issue is
what i believe is the corruption at the
absolute top the the skimming of money
you know there was a story this is a
great story shaheen nassarina was a um a
middleweight weightlifter
who was you know notoriously in the top
three in his weight class piros dimas
was his main competitor pieros dimas was
like the most decorated weightlifter of
all time one of the most easily the most
decorated greek olympian of all time and
another one georgie atzanitza who is the
coach of lasha talkadza who lasha is the
greatest weightlifter right now
so those three guys
were in a very competitive
stage and in 2000 in sydney
uh shaheen was approached by his coach
and basically said look
you cannot uh compete
and if you do compete and if you put up
winning numbers uh the rest of our team
will be popped for steroid use
and essentially uh
what the the reason for that was because
they did not pay ayan or whoever at the
top to pass those tests
okay so what shaheen did you can see in
the snatch session as he's warming up to
go snatch he's wiggling his elbow around
while he's snatching he looks fine he's
in totally he's in unbelievable shape he
even said this he's like i was in the
best shape i have ever been in
and he starts playing with his elbow in
the warm-up room and he's making sure
the camera's looking at him too he goes
up for his first snatch and he fakes an
elbow injury
walks off piros dimas is the winner i
believe georgie atzanitsa is the second
place and then someone else is third
place he doesn't even podium no
because if he did the rest of the
iranian team iranian team would feel the
wrath of the iwf this is the level of
corruption that was happening so
just to recap that
a guy that was potentially going to win
was told that he couldn't win
why what's the reason that he couldn't
come first
you know i'm not entirely sure
what the
exact specifics are is it sports betting
have they got some deal no it's not
sports betting it is so so it you have
to pay it's racketeering chris at its
highest this is crime syndicate [ __ ]
basically the iwf says you must pay us
this money so that we can either
you know push your tests under the rug
and not pop you
right it's almost like you're paying for
your medal but so every if you think if
you get tested
if you get tested you're going to piss
hot
okay you're going to get popped because
it is a it's a known fact that that
group all of those men are on drugs okay
so all of the iranians are
using yes right okay of the iranians
decided that he was gonna fake the
uh elbow injury yes right so i mean it
was there like it was right for them to
get popped then i i struggled to feel
sympathy for the guy that pretended that
he wasn't going to win because he was on
drugs and everyone else was and maybe we
were gonna get found out of course but
the problem is though chris is that
the people
who are supposed to be catching these
people know this
right they're essentially hey you could
give us a little bit of money and we'll
be fine right so do you get mad at the
cop who takes the bribe of course you
[ __ ] get mad at the cop for taking
the bribe maybe you'll feel a little
you know less uh
you know you won't feel as bad for the
person breaking the law or you will yeah
you won't feel bad for them breaking the
law but you also have to get mad at the
the cop for taking the bribe
how are we supposed to get anything done
when this level of corruption exists
all right so talk to me about the flow
of money then who is is the ioc taking
any money or do you think that they're
relatively clean
no no the ioc is anything but clean so
the ioc is kind of a bully as well right
they can make sure certain things happen
and again this is all theoretical um the
ioc is like incredibly powerful
incredibly and when things come out they
act like they're on top
right they act like they are not guilty
for any of this stuff
and they go hey federation get your [ __ ]
together
it's like it's like the ceo who breaks
the rule and blaming the people who work
for the ceo so you know it's pretty well
known that the ioc is not the most
um
you know that they're pretty dubious
if anything can expose this it's icarus
where russia was blatantly breaking
the rules as far as doping and
systematic doping and getting away with
it because they had such high standing
in the ioc
right it took until a literal
documentary and the
public discourse to be around russia and
they're cheating for them to be banned
from the olympics
okay
so what was the
press conference that was given today
was this the ioc
warning the iwf get your act together by
2023
or else you don't get to be in the
olympics in 2028 yes or else
skateboarding rock climbing and
something else will be in place so
weightlifting and boxing are going to
get kicked out for skateboarding and
rock climbing
that seems like a fair trade to me
cooks for cooks right
so so yeah i mean it's
the verbiage is clear like
kick everyone out of the iwf or else
we're going to lose this sport as we
know it okay so talk to me
ioc said and to be fair i mean are you
surprised like are you surprised no the
ioc's said your sport is a [ __ ]
shambles
no because i i'm telling you right now
chris i have been covering this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] storm for two and a half years
and i even have videos saying like
literally the death of our sport is nigh
let's fix it you know years ago i was
saying that [ __ ] and here we are now
it's finally come to a head
yeah absolutely it's been coming to a
head
the main issue here chris is that
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel that i can see
and this is the worst part it's like
right as we see the light they're just
going to close the door
the light is we just had a american
world champion meredith allwine just won
a world medal uh
last world championships we had a world
champion and a silver medalist in kate
and i and maddie rogers maddie rodgers
just got a third place medal um we had a
an olympic silver medalist these are all
things that america did not have and
we're starting to have and our youth is
starting to get better and better
because the sport is growing here and
because people care of this sport
outside of the monetary interest
if you were to compare weightlifting to
football there will never be a chance
for weightlifting to do what football
does but it's something different we are
hobbyists we are people who
are good in the weight room when you're
a child if you're good and you learn the
skill of snatching and cleaner jerking
and you pursue that you're not pursuing
it to have this dream of a life where
you can be a professional football
player where you can get a scholarship
to play football at a major university
that's not the case but there are so
many of those people and not just
30 year olds like myself right there are
little there are 15 year old kids who
are incredible at this sport who now
when they get of age in 2028 that will
be taken away from them that is what i
have a massive issue with that is not
okay and it's only because of [ __ ]
boomers in suits
for real
if thomas if
look if the doping problem was the only
problem
i don't think we would have this
discussion
but it's [ __ ] like thomas aion and
the rest of his cronies that have this
iron grip on this sport that have done
that is he still in his position no he
was forced to resign and with zero
criminal i i honestly think he still has
his money
how long has he been insane so who's in
charge now why hasn't he fixed it this
is interesting one of the guys who's an
old board member who was part of the uh
the old guard was hired he's actually a
british guy his name is mike irani and
the what's interesting is the uk
federation
didn't even like the fact that he was
selected so that goes to show that we
took out
you know uh thomas ayan and put
basically a disciple in his place yeah
version 2.0 yes
yep if you were to think about you know
uk is another country that like leads
the way in in change they're very
very harsh on doping
uh arguably harsher than what's up do
you know what our um if we got like
yukada or something yes yes is that what
it is yes okay and they're very like
they're very tough they [ __ ] got
sunny webster didn't they oh yeah and
they will continue to get him
they they pursued a rule in getting
sonny webster that
uh the us would never pursue how would
you how would you explain the series of
events that sunny went through where he
got his band and then he got his
subsequent extension
so um he got his band because he tested
positive for a sarm and i'm not sure how
long the ban was i think it might have
been four years
he was then which is the max
yes it is for first
for for your first offense it's the max
ban but he could have had that reduced
if he'd accepted like if he'd pled
guilty to it but he spent a [ __ ] ton of
money trying to find out what he thought
was a a tainted supplement that had had
that particular was it not us
ostranozole oh osterine osterine that
was it yes um and
yeah so so um
uh
then this rule is very interesting you
are not allowed to coach and or train
with people who have been uh caught
so and and if you're if if they're able
to find that they can ban the person who
was coaching they can ban even the
person who was training with that person
i'm not sure if the second version has
has happened but sunny was doing
seminars uh he continued to do seminars
he even did them in uh new zealand
australia and then the new zealand
federation and the australian federation
started complaining and then sunny uh
you know he he tacked on another three
years onto his band i think yep so
essentially a lifetime band but that's
all right he's never coming back
um but that is something that they would
never pursue here [ __ ] flying off
into the sunset with a
huge online following having tons of fun
with his model girlfriend living the
life that he wants in australia exactly
that's that's one of the things you know
to speak to
watching sunny from
i was
i was just starting to speak to him for
the show
as his first band became public
and i think
we touched on it and then james smith's
first podcast
i want to say his first or second
podcast episode is about sonny's man
it's like it's him
opening the doors
completely about what happens so i've
kind of seen this full trajectory
including the fact that he
the sport that he did where you can see
photos of him walking next to andy
murray waving his little flag
at rio
and then thinking okay um my goal
after i get through this four year ban
is to come back and do the commonwealth
games in 2022
and that you know that that's at least
part of it but i mean by the time that
his band's over he's going to have gone
from being what like a
23 year old
kid to being a 31 year old guy or a 30
year old guy
and um yeah you're right that's
basically taken the
prime of his career away from him and
he's just decided to be the most
anti-fragile
[ __ ]
on the planet and just have an awesome
time building his platform and doing
what he wants to do
outside of the institutions
well
i i would like to talk about
doping in sport
you know just generally yep um how it
works and and
why it will continue happening but
i think from what i've gathered when i
continually cover doping in sports and
corruption and weightlifting there's
this defeatist attitude from the
commenter basically being like i don't
care let them all dope
screw the ioc
screw sports just make it fun make it
fun for me
and
i have a major issue with that right
it's very simple-minded and it's almost
defeated in nature that it's absolutely
impossible to have some sort of policy
in place where
um
you know for the most part we can have
clean athletes and if that isn't
possible it's possible to have
to have the playing field be somewhat
uh more level
the biggest issue
that i found with doping and in my
experience in weightlifting but this can
carry over to many other sports is the
protection of doping athletes who dope
that's the biggest issue that i have so
if you want to roll the dice
and take drugs and try to pass tests go
ahead
you can do that in any other place in
any other endeavor in your life you can
cheat
if you don't get caught
what are we gonna do about it you know
but that is not what ends up happening
there are people who get unfair
advantages so that they can cheat
or at least cheat more than others
so you have right so so that
go ahead you have certain
athletes that are able to utilize
performance enhancers
whilst other athletes don't has your
camera just died again
yes you are do you have another battery
no i hate you
i hate you
[ __ ] said
before we started i charged it bro i was
charging it for a half hour you're a
[ __ ]
you were a [ __ ]
all right right we're switching to your
[ __ ] special needs camera by the way
though this camera is much better it's
not much better shut up right no no it's
much better than the last camera when it
when it switched over oh because you got
your new fancy yes yeah laptop okay uh
yeah the problem is that some people get
popped some people don't get popped
that's the issue
yeah and and
more than that
the problem can stem even to an even
worse place uh egypt was
i think provisionally suspended from
competing just internationally
completely because they were found
doping up 12 year olds
so so they were giving they were giving
ped peds to 12 year old girls and boys
okay
i don't care what anyone's stance on
give them all dope like let them perform
that is immoral that is wrong
100 times out of a hundred
giving children
drugs
is
is so wrong
like we we know the science behind what
anabolics do to a grown man or a grown
woman but what it does to someone going
through puberty or someone who isn't
fully developed developed that is
extremely problematic but then if you
think okay this is kind of something
with you know jordan peterson would
bring up like okay then what's the line
then what are we okay with 17 years old
18 years old 19 20 21 22
a lot of the people who
say let them all use drugs they don't
know what that means
well let me ask you why it's the case
that somebody could take puberty
blockers to reassign their gender
direction as they go through puberty but
we feel uncomfortable about somebody
enhancing their performance by using
testosterone and many people would say
in sport that's unfair and that's
potentially dangerous it seems like
i don't know the the
there are two different sets of
standards that are being used here for
people yeah and i would say most
endocrinologists who are worth their
[ __ ] salt would say
taking puberty blockers before you're
fully developed or something like that
is probably not a good idea
given you know the the countless hours
of studies of human biology it's not
suggested to do something like that
especially as a person who as yet isn't
legally allowed to vote drive or drink
alcohol in the u.s yep maybe you
shouldn't be making life-changing
decisions when you're basically still a
child that can never go back yes
irreversible yeah yes so again
the same could be said about anabolics
at what line then
person who's out there and trust me it
seems like i'm just arguing against
someone who doesn't exist but i promise
you uh there will be comments in in your
comment section there will be comments
endlessly in my section just saying
whatever
it's all entertainment for me and they
don't have any skin in the game yeah
this is my livelihood i i i want to open
a gym
when i
when i grow up
and finally
when i finally grow up no i would like
to open a gym in the future and have
youth lifters live there with the dream
of going to the olympics
i would like it to happen i would like
weightlifting to still be in the
olympics and to have it taken away from
a bunch of boomers and suits is a comp
is an issue and and furthermore to have
it taken away from other countries who
decide to dope up children that's
[ __ ] that's where i'm i'm ultimately
if it if it takes us saying hey here's a
hard stance against steroid use
i mean what do you mean a hard stance
are you trying to say that there isn't a
hard stance already
not really well in the us
anywhere actually i mean if
if this
if it were just
testing
and people getting caught if there was
no other bureaucracy surrounding it yeah
i guess i could say well
that's all we got
you know but that's the problem is once
it's too
what's the word i'm looking for it's too
multifaceted no when you when
it's too enticing
it's too enticing for leaders to
utilize
doping and anti-doping as a weapon
they use it as a weapon to manipulate
metals
to gain money
to
to you know favor one country one lifter
one athlete over another
what is that about what is it about um
weightlifting that's attracted
particularly
so much corruption and doping is it
because the sport
is benefited massively by the use of
drugs over probably most others
was that the genesis of it do you think
i think that's the genesis of it but
we're finding that you know anabolics
help i i don't i think they would help
equally in many other sports but they're
not going to help as much in let's say
soccer you know a big team sport where
your performance on your own doesn't
matter as much where raw output athletic
output is mitigated a lot more by
tactics and skill yeah and i think you
know so that's that's why cycling it
helps so much it's just output yeah it's
just output and it's just raw individual
output and the difference between a
doped up athlete and a non-doped up
athlete is massive i agree with you i
think that it is you know you're gonna
see the same level of doping in cycling
that you are in olympic weightlifting
what you're not gonna see is cycling get
taken out of the [ __ ] olympics
why is it then that weightlifting
is on the chopping block is it is there
something against the sport generally
i like to use this uh
example do you remember in step brothers
when they're in the interview and
they're wearing the tuxedos
yeah with seth rogen yeah and and
he he when they initially sit down he
goes hey i thought this tuxedos were
kind of weird but i guess i kind of like
it i think it's great and then dale
farts
really loud really hard
and then he goes
you know what on second thought those
tuxedos are a little [ __ ] up
and it's kind of the same thing with
weightlifting where the guy is wearing
the tuxedos and when we keep getting in
trouble like this it's like we're dale
farting oh yeah weightlifting is kind of
a [ __ ] up sport i think we can take it
out of these olympics
right it's like we
are
if we play by the rules they're okay
with us but if we don't we look a lot
more [ __ ] up than a major sport not
lying by the rules
because we're just not prevalent i mean
we're in at least in america we're just
not
it's not an important sport but
that's a theory that may not be true
right
i understand
it's more of a theory right like we're
we're a downtrodden
sport that's not as famous as as other
sports
and
you know to to another country that
might not be the case but i think
i i just i guess i can only compare it
to cycling
especially in america the way that we
look at cycling it's like you know we
have a ton of hobbyists we have a ton of
decent pros and decent amateurs but
we'll never look at it like we do track
and field uh you know uh gymnastics or
swimming
for some reason we just won't
i don't know man it's it's a i
understand how it's a shitty situation
especially for you as someone who has
dedicated a lot of time to this who has
got athletes who are potentially looking
at you know verging on potentially
qualifying toward that 2028 olympics
that's i understand why it would be
uncomfortable but
i don't see
that the corruption is is twofold right
so you've got the guys at the top that
are ruining it and then you have the
doping that's coming from the bottom
which is kind of destroying the sport
and the problem is that you could get
away with just the doping if you were if
you had verifiable information that you
could trust the people that were
supposed to be the ones that were
checking
yes yes and the doping would not be as
prevalent
i think it would be some sort of a
trickle-down effect
it would have to be right but again like
i said before it is too enticing to take
advantage of doping and anti-doping it
is too enticing to take control in that
way at least that's what i've
seen wasn't
russia
when they just kicked out
of some olympics recently
that but they were allowed to compete as
like the us or the the sorry the russian
federation or something
well how would you know what the story
was there
i'd not entirely no i mean i know
i know that they were kicked out like
officially kicked out but then they had
athletes basically just competing
under a different name like how the [ __ ]
does that work it's like yeah i don't
know it's it's a very
uh interesting thing there's it's it's
this thing where you can um compete
not under your country but in almost
like an athletic federation or something
like that
okay so all of the people
tons of the people that wouldn't have
been allowed to go under russia went
under the [ __ ] ussr or some [ __ ] yeah
but but they felt the heat from that
regardless like yeah they they skirted
around a little bit but they felt the
heat from literally not being allowed
could you see a world
within the next
50 years where the olympics just gets
disbanded for widespread drug use
overall
like the olympics gets cut off yep
no i don't think so it's too big of a
beast yeah it's dude it's a political
tool
it's it always has been a political tool
the olympics have always been uh
something where a country can flex i
mean this is this is really why i think
the corruption and weightlifting is so
uh so prevalent is because
these countries that don't have much
power in any other sport they found that
they were doing pretty well countries
like armenia
ukraine iran
iran uh you know these countries found a
way in to get gold medals a gold medal
for these countries is a massive deal
any medal is a massive deal it's a great
national tool for propaganda for
national pride it is a way to say [ __ ]
you to the other countries to say that
we're better it is absolutely a
competition between countries and so now
when we see
uh
you know these countries do well that
don't do well in any other sport they're
going to clamor to the way things are it
legitimates that
countries sort of sporting national
presence yeah okay yes
right does that make a little bit more
sense why it's so difficult to break
down this corruption
because
because they they don't want it to go
because it's successful for other sports
why is it that weightlifting has
permitted ira why can't iran just dope
the [ __ ] out of some cyclists and crush
cycling or
some other sport boxing or something
i think they are all right at boxing
actually but yeah i i hadn't thought
about that actually
i hadn't thought about that i think
there's like some sort of history there
i think you see eastern bloc countries
uh because they were you know part of
the ussr and the and and and
historically the ussr has been
incredibly successful in weightlifting
so then those countries break off and
now it's a great opportunity to you know
flex against the old russia
um the old ussr i i'm not entirely sure
about iran
what you actually what we see in a lot
of other countries is
some of these guys from these eastern
bloc teams they end up going to um
to these other countries and they end up
being their head coach
oh so yeah so you'll see a bulgarian
head coach of
uh the australian team or something like
that [ __ ] and that's where things get
very interesting as well what do you
think how much how widespread do you
think drug use is generally in sport so
if you were to pick i don't know like
american football right or basketball
and stuff massive you reckon yes
massive
massive the
it's it's not so that you can grow and
get bigger muscles yes you can retain
the greatest thing is you just retain
your muscle
so much easier
uh the second greatest thing is your you
can just do more work because every
powerful movement uh you're able to have
just a faster acting metabolism a faster
acting mode of recovery towards whatever
movement that is i think that basketball
might be
like it would be the most advantageous
place to use dope
because it is so it is so intense what
like a big player goes through you know
40 minutes of just back and forth and
jumping and cutting like it just would
destroy your knees the forces at which
they're constantly using and they play
so many games if you think about
football there's really not as much play
each the average play is six seconds
long
right foot basketball is non-stop it's
on hard wood you're not just cutting
you're jumping if you were to compare
that to soccer the time that one player
if you actually look at the the amount
of time a player sprints and cuts in
soccer it's not even close to to a
basketball player that would be [ __ ]
i would i would love for someone to do
uh an analysis that understands the way
that different
doping substances impact physiology and
performance and to just say look here
are some of the relative outputs that
you could expect if you were to take a
moderate sort of uh sub detectable dose
where you were cycling on and off so
here's a typical cycle that somebody
that was playing basketball would be
able to use
and here's one that somebody in cycling
could use and here's one that somebody
in soccer and weightlifting and
powerlifting and whatever and to just
have a look at the differences
the expected differences in performance
one of the problems that you're going to
get i mean let's say obviously you had
this in baseball right you had barry
bonds and that entire period where
baseball lost its
entire fan base because it was a huge
doping scandal now
the problem that you have with any sport
like baseball or basketball is the
season is so long
yes it's huge which means that if you
have no time off
the um sort of compounds that you can
use
the complexity of how you're going to
cycle in and cycle out of using
different protocols all of that's going
to be turned up to 11. yeah and i also
think you know if it doesn't take much
you just go through the majority of your
career as a
natural athlete you make it to the mba
as a natural athlete you establish
yourself as a natural athlete and then
when you want to hang on and potentially
improve because remember it's all about
improvement in any sport you want to get
better but it's very difficult to get
better when you're already some of the
best
so
uh you know that's that's where ped use
all it would take is just like a
you know like a trt dose of testosterone
and then maybe some ghd or some ghd um
human growth hormone hgh
so like gh as well would help a ton but
just just basically a trt dose for a
natural athlete that's been natural
their entire life something like that
would
increase performance com like
mind-blowingly i need derek need derek
for more plates more dates on he could
he could tell us this [ __ ]
look the way that i see it is like this
any sport where your fitness is tested
but the power output needs to be high
okay because if the power output needs
to be high that means you have to have a
musculature that can support that
however when you use a lot of power and
you use a lot of muscle for something
you end up expending a ton of energy
which in turn
is hard on your fitness so if you
constantly have to train these opposing
things right like cardiovascular fitness
is going to always oppose for
it's always going to be on the opposite
side of having a lot of muscle and a lot
of power
so what if you were able to take a
compound that was that would allow you
to retain muscle with less effort while
you can focus on fitness
right that's essentially
what
every single athlete's goal is
increase fitness increase capacity
increase the amount of work you can do
without losing the things that make you
the athlete you are
yeah i mean that's exactly what they
measure in cycling right they measure
power to weight that's what they look at
how do you get that ratio powered away i
mean it's they want to be as small as
possible but they also want to be able
to deliver the maximum amount of wattage
down okay so roll the clock forward for
me what would you do let's say that
you're in charge of the iwf now or
you're you're the ioc giving
instructions to the iwf what would your
mandate be
uh i would
i would clear clean house
every single person that was there
during ion is gone there's no question
they're gone i don't care how good of a
person they were they're gone uh
secondly i would
look over the doping
protocol and i would find a way to
verify the national testing
i think that there is some level of
innovation that can happen where we can
verify national testing then i would
have athletes required to take a certain
number of international tests per year
so if you're in that testing pool in
that elite testing pool you can just
show up to a a meet
sign up weigh in test and leave but then
you're going to know when the test is
going to be
right but
knowing when the tests are coming and
there's once one every two months it is
possible but it's less likely to take
the
enormous amount of compounds
as as well as on top of tightening up
national testing of course look chris
you can always cheat you can always
break the law you can always break the
rule we have to make it harder and we
have to be more diligent with that
like
i can sit here and give you solution
after solution and you can say well you
know they could skirt around of course
they can't
it's never going to change but there are
massive holes i mean if if we looked at
this from like an analytics perspective
we just said we just had a bunch of
economists come in bunch of
and i actually just listened to your
podcast nerds or geeks or nerds geeks
and dorks yeah uh geeks gigs gigs
because they have utility right
so we have a bunch of geeks come in
and and they say jesus this doping
protocol or anti-doping protocol like it
has massive issues here here and here
fix them
that's gotta be possible
right from my perspective it has to be
possible so something like that would
have to change
i don't know man i don't know i i it
blows my mind
that
the olympics has a very widespread drug
problem
and it kind of makes sense right because
you appreciate that people will do
whatever they need to do in order to win
and the
would you say the desire of the
individual is going to
outweigh or the the um
temptation of success is going to
outweigh
the temptation of virtue or integrity
like obviously you know getting to
the number one spot on the podium
whether you're clean or not is so
tempting to so many people
and if you're convinced enough that the
other people in your sport and in your
category are also using and you know
that you're not going to be competitive
without it then it becomes a race to the
bottom you say well look yeah i i can't
not
take this it's better for me to be
caught and kicked out because the
alternative is coming
19th
so here's the problem in weightlifting
in america we don't even have the
opportunity to race to the bottom or
sorry we don't even have the opportunity
to even play because usada is so
stringent comparatively to other
national testing how long has it been
since an american athlete got popped at
the international level
uh
as far as i'm concerned there was one
minor incident uh like what's a minor
incident ten years ago i think i i don't
know exactly what had happened but it
was sarah robles
um
i'll have to do more research on that
but i think before that you know 20 30
years so you're saying that very few
people are sneaking through the national
level testing from usada to get to
wada and then be tested at the
international level and get popped yes
okay so the number is minuscule why not
number two in that way why not just do
it that way say that look if you get
popped
at the international level
uh and your country overall is uh
disproportionately represented then
there's going to be some sort of
sanction there is
oh there is oh so so yeah so no no that
that could that you pointed out that's
exactly what happens
thailand was i mean so many countries
holy [ __ ]
uh thailand ukraine romania
azerbaijan
kazakhstan uh turkey
the list is insane they were not allowed
to bring a certain number of people to
the olympics their olympic spots were
closed so america was actually able to
bring eight
uh lifters to the olympics whereas
romania was able to bring one
okay and and then in
the thailand this is hilarious in the
thailand world championships
thailand was not even allowed to have a
team compete
the host country was not allowed to have
a team [ __ ] way swear to god and
uzbekistan um before that was it was in
i don't know where in uzbekistan it's
actually there again right now the world
championships are going on right now but
they actually might have been
turkmenistan one of the stands god
there's so many i don't know um but they
begged to allow their uh competitors to
compete at their home
competition and they were actually able
to get around that that's another point
of corruption there athletes that should
have been suspended and actually an
entire team should have been suspended
but they weren't
because it was their home meet
thailand could not pull that off
[ __ ] well dude i uh
i don't know it's it's a it's a [ __ ]
show what do you reckon what's the if
you were gonna give me odds what what do
you reckon to the percentage chance oh
god weightlifting is in the 2028
olympics
i'm going 50 50.
50 50.
it is it seems low and that is low but
i'm going 50 50. i actually said when we
were on the chopping block for 2024 i
had said
uh i think it was like
60 40
got worse
oh yeah you know why because we're
farther away yeah that's why it's scary
you got more work to do to get to the
place that you need to be and you've got
what did they say when in 2023
no i'm not it's probably right around
now december of 2023. okay so you got
two years to try and clean up an entire
sport and the governing body that does
it plus all of the athletes globally
that compete in it
yeah zach tallander good luck my friend
where should people go they want to
check out your stuff check out my
youtube channel youtube channel just
search my name
z-a-c-k-t-e-l-a-n-d-e-r if you want to
start weightlifting go to
and patreon.com as well
coach underdash zt that's where you find
me
see you soon for brisket man bye see ya
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace